[MUSIC PLAYING]
AARON SMALL: Welcome to
"Kubernetes Security The Easy
Way."
My name's Aaron Small,
and also, today, we'll
have Greg and CJ, software
engineers on the GKE security
team.
Ostensibly, we're here to
talk about GKE security,
but really this
talk is about trust.
When you choose GKE or any cloud
provider to host your product,
you're placing your
trust in them, in us.
And I don't know about you,
but I can't open the news
without reading some headline
about information security,
some cyber attack,
or the latest breach
of sensitive information,
which, to those people impacted,
is just one more
breach of trust.
Software security
is something we all
have to care about
today, but to many
it can feel like a
distraction from doing what's
most important, which
is building your product
and delighting your customers.
We're passionate about
software security.
We get up every day
delighted by the prospect
of finding that vulnerability
before the bad guys do
and building the
tools people can
use to build state of the
art, secure applications.
There are lots of
talks and blogs
and white papers you can
read that will talk about how
to harden your
Kubernetes cluster,
talk about common attacks, or
highlight recent compromises.
This talk is not about that.
Like I said, this
talk is about trust.
And in my experience, the
best way to build trust
is to be transparent.
So we're giving you a
backstage pass, into the work
we do at Google, behind the
scenes, under embargoes,
and even before you build
your first container
to keep your cluster
as secure as possible.
For those of you who
are familiar with GKE,
it's not unlikely that you
think of it as simply a managed
Kubernetes control
plane, and you
might infer from that that
the security we provide
stops there.
While we do take control plane
security quite seriously,
that's not the end of it.
Greg and CJ will discuss
how we secure your GKE
nodes, the control
plane, and the tools
that we've built that
you have at your disposal
for attack detection and
vulnerability mitigation.
CJ also has a demo
that'll demonstrate
a potential compromise scenario
and how the tools we built
make it easy to
respond and mitigate.
OK, most of you have probably
seen a diagram like this
before.
So please forgive the
early morning GKE 101.
I do want to give a
little bit of groundwork,
though, for the rest
of the presentation.
GKE, in the simplest terms, is a
hosted Kubernetes control plane
and some number of
Kubernetes nodes.
You, the developers
and administrators,
interact with the control
plane and your users interact
with the containers that
you've deployed on the nodes.
The control plane
manages your workloads.
It manages what nodes belong to
the cluster and the certificate
authority that
handles authentication
of the node agents,
also called kubelets.
The nodes themselves
execute containers,
receive configuration
data, secrets, et cetera,
that they need to function
from the control plane.
It's on those nodes where
the aforementioned hardening
guides and best
practices come into play.
As you get more familiar
with Kubernetes,
you'll customize this and
configure it and really make it
your own.
It can get as complex and as
unique as you want to make it.
The security of this
phase follows the shared
responsibility
model, meaning we're
responsible for the security
of the infrastructure, itself,
and you're responsible
for what you deploy there.
You manage, among other
things, the node specification,
which has all the standard
VM knobs you might expect,
number of cores, amount of
RAM, the operating system,
whether or not there's
a GPU attached,
what services and workloads
you've deployed there,
and any Google Cloud
Service accounts
that you use to talk to
other Google Cloud Services.
But today we're talking about
what Google does for you.
So with that, I want to
hand off to Greg, who's
going to discuss node security.
GREG CASTLE: Thanks, Aaron.
So I'm going to start out the
behind the scenes tour talking
about node security.
I'm going to build this picture
up in a few different layers.
So we're going to start at
the VM provisioning layer.
There's been a number of other
Google talks, in the past,
about the great
security work Google's
doing below that layer, things
like hardware and firmware
security.
I'm going to skip that in
favor of covering new material
and making sure we get
to Kubernetes stuff.
So starting at the virtual
machine layer, then operating
system on top, then the kubelet,
and how we bootstrap the trust
in that system, and
finally, the system
containers that make up
Kubernetes and other Google
containers that we run.
So starting at the VM
provisioning layer.
So when you create
a cluster with GKE,
you get nodes that are
automatically provisioned
into a virtual private cloud.
We create a firewall that
has just enough privilege
for the control plane
to be able to talk
to the nodes and the nodes to
be able to talk to each other.
The VMs have discs that
are encrypted at rest.
You can read all about
that at this link here.
And they really benefit
from a lot of work
that Google's done over the
years to harden our hypervisor.
So Google has spent a large
amount of security time
making sure that VMs running
on that same shared hardware
are really well isolated
from each other,
and our VMs inherit all that
great work that Google's
done previously.
As an optional feature-- at the
moment it's currently beta--
when you create a cluster, you
can make it a private cluster.
And that means that
you essentially take it
off the public internet.
So your nodes get private IP
addresses, RFC 1918 addresses.
And whenever you do
that, it's a good--
I think, when you don't need
a service on the internet,
it's always good to be able to
remove it from the internet.
You kind of take out a bunch
of attacks related to just
general internet scanning.
So that's the virtual
machine layer.
So the next layer up is
the operating system.
So the default operating
system that we offer on GKE
is the Container-Optimized OS.
We also offer
Ubuntu by Canonical.
But in the interest
of time today, I'm
just focusing on COS.
Canonical also has a
great security team
and builds a great OS, but
I'm talking about COS today.
So this is an OS
that's built by Google.
It's based on Chromium OS.
It's a really minimal OS.
It's really just enough
OS to run containers
and not much else.
And that's good,
because less code
means less vulnerabilities,
less attack surface, less
maintenance burden,
less patching.
And all of that stuff is good.
We've also spent a
significant amount of time
hardening this operating system.
So we've enabled a whole bunch
of different kernel security
features and set a
bunch of secure defaults
at the kernel layer and various
other operating system knobs.
And the idea there is to
make that initial execution
step of any attack much harder.
So if we can put in
a memory protection
in the kernel that makes
it harder for attackers
to execute, that's a win.
We've also spent
quite a bit of time
trying to make it
harder to persist
through a number of
different mechanisms.
So things like an
immutable root file
system, making the
root system read-only,
and having a verified
boot chain means
that a number of
those traditional ways
to persist on an
operating system
are made much harder on COS.
We're also enabling
features like eBPF
to allow third party security
products, particularly
detection products,
to run on GKE.
We want those products
to work well on GKE.
And there's more work
you can do here if you
want to go the extra mile.
So COS also supports
seccomp and apparmor,
so you can really write
a very specific hardening
for your particular application.
If you'd like to go
that far into it,
you can define the normal
behavior of your application.
And the idea there is that,
if an attacker is trying
to operate outside
the bounds of what
is normal for your
application, then
it should be blocked
by these technologies
and make their
life a lot harder.
And you can read more about
COS and all the hardening
and security work we're
doing there at this address.
And for all these
like little links
that I'm firing up
on the screen here,
I have a giant slide at
the end with a big list.
So if you just want to take
a photo of that one, you can.
I also briefly wanted to
mention the team behind COS.
So we have a dedicated team
that is working on maintenance,
testing, security patching.
We also have a lot of
Google in-house Linux kernel
expertise, so that benefits
the whole Linux ecosystem.
Those people are developing
new kernel security features
and also finding vulnerabilities
and patching them,
but we're also benefiting
from that expertise with COS.
So we're driving features
through the kernel and into COS
that we're making use of.
So I'll just give you a
second to absorb this diagram.
We're up to the next level now.
So we've got VM, OS, and then
on top of that is Kubernetes.
So this is a fairly
simplified version
of how the kubelet
bootstraps its trust.
So we're going to
walk through this
and give you an idea
of how that happens.
So what makes a Kubernetes
node a Kubernetes node?
It's when you have
a kubelet that's
registered with the API server
and can authenticate to it.
So we start down the bottom of
this picture with the node VM,
where the kubelet's running,
and it retrieves a bootstrap key
from the metadata server,
which is running outside the VM
but beside it.
So it retrieves that
key and then creates
a Certificate Signing Request--
it's a standard X.509
Certificate Signing Request--
and sends that to
the API server.
The API server receives
that CSR and checks
that it's authenticated
with that bootstrap key.
It does some other
checks on the CSR itself,
and then it sends it off, via
a webhook, to a signing API.
And that's actually running
outside the cluster.
So that hosted control plane
is running on a GCE VM,
and the Google prod box is--
you may have heard of Borg,
our internal infrastructure.
So that's signing APIs.
And keys are held externally.
So that call goes
out to that API,
the certificate
request gets signed,
and the cert propagates
back to the kubelet.
The interesting
part of all of this
is that the signing
keys are actually
held externally to the cluster.
So we have an extra trust
boundary in between those two.
Properties of this procedure.
The traffic is all
authenticated and encrypted.
The trust comes from
the virtual machine.
We end up with a per node
X.509 identity, which
is actually really important.
CJ will talk later
about how this
is useful in control
plane security
with the node authorizer.
I mentioned the CA
is off the cluster.
And in the future, we're
looking at how we can improve
this bootstrapping process.
And in Kubernetes 1.11, my
team contributed some code
that will allow the kubelet
to bootstrap itself using
a trusted platform module.
And the idea there
is that the kubelet
will no longer have to handle
the key material directly.
So that will be a security win.
So once we have a
kubelet, that isn't all
that we need for the cluster.
There's a bunch of other cluster
services that need to run.
So there's Kubernetes things,
like kube-proxy, cluster DNS,
and there's also
Google extra add-ons,
like logging containers,
monitoring containers, as well
as things like a
container runtime.
So Google does a lot of
work to maintain these, make
sure they are working, make
sure they work with the control
plane, and make sure
they scale appropriately.
But the security-relevant
pieces are
that we deliver these in a
defensible configuration,
that you wouldn't find things
like a container runtime
port listening on the open
internet, for example.
We also look at the security of
all these containers regularly,
so we're scanning the containers
referenced in the Kubernetes
source code for
vulnerabilities and we're
patching those where
patches are missing.
So that's kind of what we
do with those containers.
There's actually some work
here for you, the GKE user,
to do with these
containers, as well.
So you really need to be
able to upgrade your nodes
to get those patches.
So I just talked about the
security patching process.
Essentially, how that works is
we will patch the container,
release a new version
of the container,
and then update Kubernetes
to reference that new version
of the container.
And when we do that, we'll
bump the node version.
So that a node upgrade is
essentially like the rising
tide that lifts the
container ship that
has all the containers on it.
So to make that
process easier, there's
actually an auto
upgrade feature that you
can opt into, so
you can say, Google,
please handle the upgrades of
these nodes, automatically.
I don't want to think about it.
And to give you some control
over when that happens,
you can actually specify
a maintenance window.
So that's a four-hour window
that says to Google, hey,
please do your upgrade,
your maintenance tasks
within this window.
So that's node security.
We talked about VM
provisioning, in terms
of hypervisor, firewalls,
the operating system, kernel
hardening, security patching,
Kubernetes trust bootstrap,
in terms of how the CA works,
and the system containers
and how they're
patched and upgraded.
The takeaway I'd like you
to take, from this section,
is that Google's doing a
whole bunch of work here,
so that you don't have to
care about any of this,
and you can focus
on your application.
But the one thing
you do need to do
is look after your
node upgrades.
So I'm going to
hand it over to CJ
to talk about control
plane security.
CJ CULLEN: Thanks, Greg.
So Greg gave us a
good overview of what
GKE provides you in terms of
the managed node environment.
But a lot of what you
think of, of the security
that GKE provides you, is the
managed Kubernetes control
plane.
So on GKE, each
cluster control plane
is separated, by a VM boundary,
from every other cluster
control plane.
So that means that
the API server
that you talk to
is entirely yours,
the etcd database that houses
your Kubernetes API resources
is all yours, and
then the add-ons
that run in your
cluster are all yours.
The Kubernetes API
that you talk to
is the same Kubernetes that you
would get running it yourself.
But on GKE, that's
all managed by Google.
So a big part of that isolation
is the per cluster certificate
authority.
Greg mentioned it, that
governs the node credentials
that the node agents use to
authenticate to the managed
control plane.
It also governs the
server side credentials
that the managed control point
authenticates itself with.
The key for that,
as Greg mentioned,
is held off the cluster
for defense in depth,
encrypted at rest.
The fact that it
is a per cluster CA
means that we get a
simplified chain of trust.
We don't depend on a public
CA or PKI for this to work.
And then that key is
rotatable on-demand,
either just for good
hygiene or as part
of an incident response.
So Greg mentioned
the per node identity
that you get as part of that
kubelet trust bootstrap.
And that per node identity
becomes super important
when we start thinking about how
nodes interact with the managed
control plane to
manage what workloads
they're actually running.
So node agents have
only the permissions
they need to do their job.
So that means that
one node is only
allowed to update
status about itself,
and it's only allowed
to see things,
like secrets and
config maps, that
are actually pertinent
to the workloads that
are scheduled onto it.
And this is just another
defense in depth step
that helps make a compromise
of one node stay limited
to just that node.
So another huge benefit you
get, from the managed control
plane that GKE gives you, is
the seamless authentication
with the same user
accounts that you already
have on Google Cloud.
So whether you are taking
a look at usage or digging
through logs in
the Cloud console,
or you're on the command line
debugging your Kubernetes
application using G
Cloud and kube control,
you're the same user with the
same strong authentication
that you get anywhere
else from Google Cloud.
Building on top of that
authentication story,
GKE is integrated with
Google IAM, which gives you
the ability to manage
the permissions,
grant your team just the
permissions they need
to do their job, and
then see and enforce
that policy in one place across
your entire organization.
For advanced Kubernetes
users, this all
plays nice with Kubernetes
RBAC for access control.
So now that you know who is
supposed to be able to do what,
it's still really
helpful to have
that audit trail,
after the fact,
to see what actually happened.
So the pertinent
info you want on GKE
is what has accessed
the Kubernetes API
and also what operations
have taken place
on the underlying GKE clusters.
So if you've ever been
in a situation where
you had an incident, and then
you looked after the fact, just
to realize that you forgot to
turn on logs, well, on GCP,
we give you 400
days of retention,
of what we call admin
activity logs, by default.
So that's mutating operations.
So on GKE, that's things like
creating new Kubernetes pods
or upgrading the version
of your GKE nodes.
For everything else, for
things like read access
to the Kubernetes API, you
can enable data access logs
and those get
retained for 30 days.
Those get ingested directly
to Stackdriver, where
you can analyze them there.
If you have another
tool that you
like to analyze
your logs with, you
can easily export logs from
Stackdriver using something
like Cloud Pub/Sub.
So to show off how powerful
all of these features
can be together, I'm going to
set up a little demo scenario.
So we're going to
say that we have
this continuous integration,
continuous deployment
system, that, every
hour, it's going
to build a new version
of our application
and it's going to then
push that application,
artifacts up to
Google Cloud Storage,
and then once that's
done, we're going
to deploy the new version
of our application
out to our GKE cluster
for some testing.
So that's all good.
We've got that
running, and then,
one day, we get
the dreaded email.
Google has detected that some
credential, from our project,
appears to have been
exposed somewhere
on the public internet.
We dig back a little bit, and
sure enough, we accidentally
checked in our private key to
a public source control repo.
So what that means is
that the deploy piece
of this CI/CD system we set up
is now using a credential that
has access to a GKE
cluster, and that credential
may be exposed somewhere.
So how do we respond to this?
So let's pop over
to the Cloud console
and walk through
some of our options.
So the first thing you would
want to do in this scenario
is pop into the IAM
Service Accounts tab
and rotate that key.
And you do that just by coming
over here to create a new key,
provision that out to
the system that needs it,
so that you can take this
without any downtime,
and then you delete the key
that we saw was compromised.
I'm not going to do that yet.
For the sake of
demonstration, we're
actually going to walk
through what could have
happened in this situation.
So the next thing you
want to take a look at
is what permissions did that
service account actually have.
So if you go into
the Permissions tab,
we can see that our CI/CD
pipeline service account here,
we granted it the
CI/CD Pipeline Role.
Now what that is actually
an IAM custom role.
So if I pop over to
the custom Roles tab,
you'll be able to see where
I defined the CI/CD Pipeline
Role.
And clicking into that, we see
that the only two permissions
contained in that
role are the ability
to get deployments and the
ability to update deployments.
We have a very
simplified CI/CD system.
All it's doing is updating
the container version
to point to the new
application we just built.
Now deployments.update is still
a fairly elevated permission.
It allows you, like
I just mentioned,
to change the container
image or to even
change parameters
or the environment
that your application
is running in.
So we're not completely
out of the woods
yet, but, by limiting
these permissions
to exactly what this thing
needs to get its job done,
we've at least
limited the surface
area of the potential attack.
So now that we've seen what this
thing could do, let's go ahead
and take a look at
what it has done.
So if we pop over to
the Stackdriver Logs,
and we look at the Kubernetes
logs, we see it's fairly noisy.
The Kubernetes API is
a pretty noisy place.
There's a lot of
activity going on.
Luckily, in this
Stackdriver UI, we
can easily filter
this via text search.
We know our service
account had CI/CD in it.
And we see that the thing
that's happened, so far,
is mostly what we expect.
It's our hourly push
to our GKE cluster.
So far, so good.
We can dig in here, find
some interesting information
in this.
We can even start
streaming the logs
that we see new
activity as it happens.
So let's switch
gears a little bit
and think about
what this might look
like from a potential
attacker scenario.
So a common way you
might see this happen
is an attacker might write
a very shallow, broad script
that's just scanning the
internet for anything that
looks like credentials.
Then you might take a
really quick attempt
at trying to make use
of those credentials,
trying to make money
off that, probably,
by implanting a malicious
application somewhere.
So I've written
up a little script
that's just going to pretend
to scan the internet for keys.
So everything you see in
white is pretend stuff,
but the things that are in
green are actual commands,
and then the things
that are in red
are the responses
from those commands.
So we're going to scan
the internet for keys.
And sure enough, it came across
our exposed service account key
for that CI/CD pipeline.
So the next thing it
will do is configure
the shell to make use
of those credentials.
And we're going to
go ahead and attempt
to implant our malicious
application as a Kubernetes
pod in this cluster.
And you'll see that, luckily,
that request was denied.
So the error we got
back from Kubernetes
is that we did not have
enough permissions to make
this request.
If you remember back to the IAM
custom role we took a look at,
we had the ability to get
deployments and update
deployments, but we didn't have
the ability to create pods.
So that's good.
So maybe the script tries
to create these things
a couple more times, but it's
going to fail every time.
And if this is just a
shallow, cheap scan,
maybe it just moves on.
And we were lucky that
we got safe there.
Now, if you were watching
over here on the right,
you saw these logs
start to pop up.
And so, in this scenario,
it's fairly obvious
to see where the anomalous
activity came in from.
In other incidents, it
may not be this easy.
We can directly see that this
double exclamation point,
red thing got an error.
We can dig into how
exactly that happened.
But in real incidents,
you might have better luck
analyzing logs further,
here, or exporting them
to a different system to do
more in-depth processing.
That's as easy as
creating an export.
You can send that to
BigQuery, give it a name,
create the sync.
I've already done that, so let's
pop over to this BigQuery tab,
where I have streamed logs
to a BigQuery data set.
I've already
written out a query.
I'm going to take a look
for any calls that have
come from this service account.
But they came from
outside what I'm
going to pretend is
our corporate IP range.
We know our CI/CD
system is only going
to be calling from this
IP range that we expect,
so if we do see accesses from
this service account coming
from elsewhere,
we'd like to know.
That's unusual.
And then, just from
that, I'm going
to gather some
pertinent information.
So we take a look at this query.
And sure enough, it's going to
pop up with those three calls
that that script just made.
We see, from the HTTP code,
our attacker was unsuccessful,
didn't have enough permissions.
And we have the
IP of the caller,
right here, that can help inform
some of our additional incident
response.
So I'm not going to go
any deeper into incident
response here.
Incidents are fairly unique.
I just wanted to highlight
some of the tools
that we've provided that
help you start to begin
your incident response.
If you've ever been in
a situation like this,
you know how critical
it can be to get
good, solid information quickly
to stakeholders and leadership.
So we walked through how
GKE's integration with Google
authentication gives
you a single place
to go manage and rotate
your credentials.
We saw how GKE works with IAM to
grant granular least privilege
permissions and set and
enforce that across your org.
And then lastly, we saw how
GKE's automatic audit logging
gives you the ability to have
a solid incident response
story without having to have
remembered to turn it on.
And with that, I'm going
to hand it back over
to Greg, who's going to
talk through some real life
examples of vulnerability
management in GKE.
GREG CASTLE: Thanks, CJ.
So I wanted to talk a little
about vulnerability management.
It's something that often
doesn't get a lot of air time.
And I wanted to do that with
some example case studies.
Now these case studies are
just two examples in time.
I think they're
both interesting,
but not every vulnerability is
going to work out like this.
Each vulnerability tends
to be unique on a number
of different axes.
So with that caveat, the
first one I want to talk about
is some vulnerabilities
that were
found in some software called
Dnsmasq, back in October,
in 2017.
So this is open source software.
It is a very well-used piece of
software not written by Google.
It's open source.
And it provides critical DNS
services and other networking
services for many, many
different companies.
It's very well-used.
It runs on laptops, desktops,
servers, IoT devices,
lots of different places.
So I'm going to step through
how the vulnerability was found,
how we fixed it, and what
the outcome was for GKE.
So how was this
vulnerability found?
So Google employs a bunch of
really world-class security
researchers, internally.
They are focused on
finding vulnerabilities
in our own products
and fixing them,
as well as finding
vulnerabilities
in critical pieces of
internet infrastructure
and making the internet safer.
So in this case--
oh, actually, and we also
have the Vulnerability Rewards
Program, where we engage the
external security research
community and we pay
them for their work
through a bug bounty program.
So in this case,
for Dnsmasq, this
was a Google-discovered
vulnerability.
So Google security researcher
found a whole series
of vulnerabilities, actually.
And if you're interested
in kind of geeking out
on the details of
these vulnerabilities,
you can go read all
about them here.
It's not really super-relevant
for this presentation,
but the worst of them was
a remote code execution.
So the Google
security researchers
started working with the
maintainer of Dnsmasq, who's
an external party,
doesn't work at Google.
Together they came
up with a fix that
fixed the vulnerabilities
that had been found.
And then we started a
worldwide multi-company
coordinated disclosure effort.
This was really complicated
disclosures to try and get
as many people
patched as possible.
And we enlisted the help of
the US CERT, the US Computer
Emergency Readiness
Team, with that effort.
So what did this mean for GKE?
So internally, we identified
that GKE and Kubernetes
depended on Dnsmasq.
And that meant that we
knew we were vulnerable.
And so we kicked off the
Kubernetes security response
process, and that starts with us
emailing the Kubernetes product
security team, which we
actually sit on as well, too.
So that's a handful of
representatives from companies,
Google, Microsoft, Red Hat.
In this case, CJ actually led
the vulnerability response,
so we volunteered
to take the lead.
In other cases, it
might be someone
from Microsoft or
someone from Red Hat,
all very experienced security
engineers with deep expertise
in Kubernetes.
So we took the lead on this
one, which was, essentially,
working out how to
fix it in Kubernetes.
So we figured out
that we had to patch
kube DNS with this new fix
that had been developed
with the Dnsmasq maintainer,
and release a new version
of that container.
And once we'd gotten
the fix kind of settled,
we had to build and stage
quite a number of releases.
So the releases for the
security release process,
which is extensively documented
at this link-- you can go
read all about it.
But essentially, what
we were able to do
was create Kubernetes releases
for three different release
branches, and even,
actually, one more,
because 1.8 was about to
be released at the time.
All of those contained--
we were able to patch
all those branches,
with the fix and release
the fix on the same day as the
public vulnerability went out.
And for GKE, this meant that,
as part of the managed service,
we were able to make a change
on the masters that rolled out
a change to kube DNS
across the clusters.
And so the outcome
for GKE customers
was that we were able to
patch this vulnerability,
at the public release time,
without any action required
on the part of the customer.
So I think that's kind
of the ideal outcome,
that Google spends a whole bunch
of engineering hours figuring
out how to do all this and
just fixes it for everyone.
And you don't even
have to worry about it.
You may not have even been
aware of this vulnerability.
It won't always
work out like that.
But I think that
is the ideal case.
The second case study I
wanted to talk about briefly
is the Spectre and
Meltdown vulnerabilities.
So this was from early
January this year.
So these were very
interesting vulnerabilities.
Probably most of the
people in this room
have heard about them.
If you haven't,
they were discovered
by Google Project Zero.
There were vulnerabilities
in most modern CPUs.
They're caused by the
speculative execution feature.
I'm also not going to dig
in to the details of this.
If you do want details,
there's an entire Next session
that has actually
already happened,
but you can find it on YouTube.
If you want to dig
into how Google found
these vulnerabilities
and how we fixed them
across the whole
infrastructure, that
should be a really
interesting talk.
There's also a blog post.
And if you just
Google these things,
you'll find out
a ton about this.
They were very well-known.
So what did this mean for GKE?
So we knew that we had to
make virtual machine changes.
So there was changes
necessary to the hypervisor
to prevent one VM accessing
the host memory of the hardware
machine that was running
the VM and getting access
to another VM on
the same machine.
So we needed some hypervisor
changes to fix that problem.
And then, as a second
layer of defense,
we also needed some
changes in the kernel,
enabling some new
protections there.
That required a
new version of COS.
So that was essentially a
second layer of protection,
and you'll hear Google's
security engineers
talk about two layers
of defense a lot.
So we're always looking
for two layers of defense
where we can find them.
It doesn't always happen,
but our experience
has told us that, when we can
get two layers of defense,
that's a really good thing.
And it really helps.
So there was lots of testing
involved, many, many hours
of engineering time spent
on getting these fixes
and testing them,
testing upgrade paths,
testing performance
in particular,
because these new
kernel security
features had some significant
performance changes.
So the outcome for GKE, I
think, was actually pretty cool.
So we were able to
live-migrate using technology
that GCE basically
built. So we were
able to take those nodes that
were running customer workloads
and live-migrate them onto that
new version of that hypervisor
without any interruption.
I think that's actually
pretty awesome,
given the scale of
these vulnerabilities
and how complex they were.
There was still some
customer work required.
So that upgrade to the COS image
did require a node upgrade,
like I mentioned
previously, but we
were able to deliver that first
defense without any customer
effort required.
So in general, how do
we handle communications
for security patches
and similar issues?
If there is a serious
security vulnerability,
we'll send targeted emails
if it requires some action
by the customer.
And for everything else, we
have a security bulletins page
that you can see at this link.
And it has a RSS feed you
can also subscribe to.
All these links are
at the end, too.
I also briefly wanted to
mention, again, the Google
Vulnerabilities Reward Program.
So we've built on a lot of
success, with this program,
with Android, Chrome, and all
of Google's web properties.
And I just wanted to
call out, specifically,
that it does apply to GKE.
This is not a new announcement.
It has applied for
a very long time.
But this essentially gives
us a force multiplier
for engaging that external
security research community
and getting vulnerabilities,
finding new vulnerabilities
and fixing them as
quickly as possible.
So before I hand
it back to Aaron,
I just wanted to mention the
key takeaway, from that section,
I think, is that Google is
doing a whole bunch of work
in vulnerability management to
make it as easy as possible,
for you, as the customer.
It won't always be zero
effort on your behalf,
but we're really trying to
minimize that effort, that you
need to put in, on those kind
of annoying problems of patching
vulnerabilities.
AARON SMALL: OK, so
I feel like we just
shotgunned a lot of
content at you guys,
so I'm going to give
a pretty brief recap.
Greg discussed the
layered approach
that we take to GKE
security, all the way from VM
provisioning up to
Kubernetes configuration.
CJ discussed control
plane security
as well as gave us
a demo of how you
might handle the compromise
of a sensitive secret.
And then Greg came
back and walked us
through a couple of
marquee vulnerabilities,
over the last year or so,
and how we managed them.
So what's the point
of all of this?
What message are we sending?
What do we want
you to take away?
That's that software security
is our full time job on GKE.
And we want to give to you
that trustworthy infrastructure
you need to build
state of the art, world
changing secure applications.
This is one of the photo slides.
We have a ton of great container
security content at Next.
Some of this has
already happened,
so it will be
available on YouTube.
I would highly recommend
going back and watching them.
We also have several
more talks today
that I would definitely
encourage you to go visit
if you care about security.
I'll be at most
of them, if I can.
And this is the links slide
that Greg referenced before.
Glad it's big enough
for you to read.
Thank you.
That is all the content
that we have so far.
[MUSIC PLAYING]